[Music]
the indian are the egyptian gods that
hail from a pocket dimension called the
celestial heliopolis they could alter
their appearance and manipulate matter
they have cosmic and elemental energies
that they could wield at will they can
also choose a model and use them as
avatars of their divine power and will
so these gods although they exist at 9
at a time there have been multiple
changes in the lineup which means that
like the asgardian gods they too can be
killed or will perish in time so here in
this video we will take a look at 15 of
these egyptian gods and assess in the
end of the video who the present nine of
the indian are in moon night
the first one is ra also known as atom
or amon ra he is the god of the sun and
the king of the gods and one of the most
powerful of the pantheon he represents
the burning masculine virility of the
sun he stands for the sovereignty of
masculinity logic and raw power he is a
creator god and later was turned into
the demogorge the god-eater who resides
in the sun and only comes out to eat
aforementioned gods he is the main
progenitor of the race of gods
collectively known as the idiots the
father to them all
next we have shoe and toughnut when ra
returned to the sun and became the
demogorge shu his son took up his throne
as the god of the air and his twin
sister teffnet became the goddess of the
reign they sired the first generation of
gods which included the likes of gep and
nut respectively the god of the earth
and the goddess of the heavens
who succeeded them when the time came
for them to retire due to old age and
let the younger generation of gods to
rise and continue the cycle
next we have gib and nut
gep was the egyptian god of the earth
and one of the confirmed mythological
member of the idiot of heliopolis he
could also be considered as the father
of snakes it was believed that in
ancient egypt that gepp's laughter
created earthquakes and that he allowed
crops to grow his sister and consort not
is the goddess of the sky stars cosmos
mothers astronomy and the universe she
was seen as a star-covered nude woman
arching over the earth or sometimes as a
cow
she was depicted wearing the waterpot
sign that identifies her in marvel gap
and not rule as pharaohs of egypt
immortal pharaohs until they were
imprisoned with the others in a pyramid
by the god seth
then we have osiris he was the eldest
child of gep god of the earth and not
the goddess of the heavens the brother
of seth
isis and nephthys
he was the egyptian benevolent god of
the dead as gepp stepped down from
rulership osiris was chosen to succeed
him to the dismay of seth who wished to
rule heliopolis this set up the
long-standing feud between seth and the
other gods osiris is a formidable
combatant particularly in using his
energy manipulating capabilities in
combat situations
then we have isis as the goddess of
fertility and domestication isis taught
ancient egyptian models the arts of
medicine and domestication she was also
a powerful sorceress after her husband
osiris was murdered and dismembered by
his jealous brother younger brother seth
isis used her sorcery prowess to
reassemble her husband and bring him
back isis possessed a vast control over
elemental forces including the ability
to restore life to the dead
then we have nepthes she was yet another
deity of the dead not to be confused
with death but of the death of the dead
souls she was also the goddess of the
night she was married to seth but was
impregnated by osiris at some point of
time which further led to the enmity
between seth and osiris later on from
that union a famous and feared god would
come to be and that is anubis
then we have seth said is among the most
powerful of the all the egyptian gods he
was the brother of isis osiris and
nephthys he was also seen as a god of
death more precisely as the serpent god
of death
due to his jealousy of osiris at certain
point of time he managed to kill osiris
and dismember his body into 14 different
parts and scattered it into the winds he
was also a fierce rival and enemy of
horus the son of osiris
now we come to hathor seen as the
lioness goddess hathor was the daughter
of the god of the son amun ra or jasra
she is a beast metaphorically and
literally speaking
at one point of time when the people of
ancient egypt rebelled against ra he
sent hathor to punish humanity but her
bloodlust transformed her into sekhmet a
power of destruction segment released
such fury against mortal foes that raf
feared that she would destroy the human
race entirely legends state that sekhmet
even shredded half of egypt because her
bloodlust was uncontrollable once
unleashed
next we come to anubis is the
jackal-headed god of death and rebirth
along with being the god of funerals
mummification and the afterlife as the
god of death his main role was to usher
souls into the afterlife he attended the
weighing scale in which it was
determined whether a soul would be
allowed to enter the afterlife anubis
was very feared
even among the members of the indian and
was more powerful than many of the other
gods
now we come to konchu konchu is the
nocturnal god of the moon of vengeance
and for travelers he was the son of ra
and was described as the greatest god of
the great gods he represented the moon a
universal symbol for redemption power
so not being able to enter the earthly
plane so throughout history he would
pick a champion who would work as an
avatar of him and be guided by his will
that lone warrior will be called the
moon knight in the mcu he is seen as
being glad in mummy robes holding a
scepter with a crescent moon on top and
having a raven skull for a head
so after conscious we come to bast one
of the elders of the init as early as 10
000 bc bass was worshiped as a panther
god granting power to worshipers and
descendants the most well-known fact
about bass is that it is the wakandan
panther god and is responsible for
protecting the wakandan kingdom as well
as granting power to the ancient line of
kings and warriors known as black
panthers however in egypt bass was
worshiped primarily in the city of
bubastas as a goddess of pleasure
dancing and music
so different
so lastly we come to horus
and now we have the falcon god one of
the most powerful and the most
well-known of all the egyptian gods
being the son of osiris who was
instrumental in helping anubis and isis
in collecting the dismembered parts of
his father's body and resurrecting him
horus was also the same god who would
battle seth for centuries and ultimately
win in the end horus carries a staff
with a large blade at one end and a hook
at the other he can use that staff to
focus his energy powers with great
efficiency
so now we come to the question which are
the nine goals of the idiot in moon
knight
well there are six which have been
confirmed by stephen grant in the museum
as he was conversing with his manager
the one seen on that poster was shu
horus osiris defnut hathor and gep
since konchu is the power source behind
the moon knight who is his avatar
then we can say that he is the seventh
on this list
and now there are two more spots so with
arthur harrow worshiping and drawing
power from another one called amid we
can clearly say that she also might be
the eighth member
but then again she could be on the
opposing side to the indian so
personally i think the wakandan deity
boss is the eighth member
being in the same cinematic universe and
then lastly we see an avatar of anubis
trying to kill stephen but only to fall
to moon night so anubis might be the
ninth member of the indian
anyway this is still an educated guess
the nine members of the init will
be revealed eventually in moon night and
let's see if we are true like if our
guess is true so we have shu horus
osiris definite hatha and gab then we
have consu uh bars and then anubis
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam